من قمه الهرم العسكري الاسرائيلي نبره
لافته واقرار غير مسبوق عن ثمن باهظ
تكبدته اسرائيل جراء العمليات الاخيره
وحاجه للتحقيق فيما جرى في المقابل نبره
اسرائيليه اخرى نحو مزيدا من التصعيد
وحديث عن ضروره تحول التعامل الامني من
الدفاع الى الهجوم وفقا لوزير الامن
الداخلي الاسرائيلي اسئله تتشكل عن طبيعه
الثمن الذي تقول اسرائيل ان هدفعته وعن
انعكاساته خاصه مع سياسات على الارض تزيد
التاجيج من حصار مدن الى حملات دهم
واعتقال وهدم منازل
اذا يواصل الجيش الاسرائيلي فرض طوق امنيا
مشدد على منطقه اريحا عاقبه مقتل مستوطن
في اطلاق نار بمنطقه الاغوار جنوب البحر
الميت قوات الاحتلال نشرت حواجز عسكريه في
محيط المدينه وعززت قواتها بحثا عن منفذي
هجوم الاثنين بينما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان القوات الامن الامنيه تواصل العمل على
كافه المستويات العسكريه والمخابراتيه
بحثا عن منفذي عمليتي اطلاق النار في
منطقه حواره وفي الاغوار جنوب اريحا
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال ثمانيه فلسطينيين
على الاقل في بلده عبد في جنين واخرين في
مخيم العروب في الخليل جاء ذلك بعد اقتحام
مخيم شعفاط في القدس واعتقالي شاب فلسطيني
وفي بلده جبل المكبر جنوب شرق القدس
المحتله هدمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
منزلا بحجه البناء دون ترخيص
وفي بلده العيساويه شمال شرقي القدس
المحتله اقتحمت قوات من شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وحصلت منزلا ثم شرعت الجرافه
في هدم المنزل بحجه عدم حصول صاحبه على
ترخيص للبناء